now in you mentioned bill condon the
director of this film you know you
previously worked at them on gods and
monsters one of my favorite films of
yours and you worked with them obviously
on kinzie as well as the Fifth Estate I
believe obviously you two have a
fondness for the director given that you
return to work with him what was it like
to collaborate with him on this
particular film well as enjoyable as
ever you you you meet bill he he's not a
tall man he he was owlish spectacles and
on occasion he stammers and yet we'd do
anything he asked so heroes don't have
to look like heroes you know the and his
two things and then I know Laura agrees
but that he sets a tone when you go into
the set and and the bill will be there
and he'll be on the floor available for
the question going right checking
everyone's all right all the work
planned everything everything nothing
can go really go wrong and he's just
there and everybody there is is his
devotee I'm slavishly it's just there's
a good atmosphere you know it's all
right there's no one like there's no one
shrieking in their trailer about it no
he couldn't it everything's out in the
open is lovely and then when that man
just quite it says something in your ear
after a take whatever it is I don't
question it that's Bill Condon said that
thank you you know when you do it these
right you know so it does make it all a
lot easier than it can be you know and
some I had a director said to me
whenever will you stop being so Royal
Shakespeare Company
I suppose he meant I was overacting
another point well taken but bill bill
would just say um what about make it
just a little bit quieter oh thank you
yes i see sherlock holmes is the most
played portrayed movie character in the
world with over 70 actors having played
in over 200 films did you have any
reservations whatsoever about that
aspect don't know as familiar things you
can't when you play Hamlet worried that
yeah thousands of actors have played
Hamlet in fact take comfort because a
lot of them were very good because
they're very fit a good part and the
first thing I noticed about this was
that silicones is a wonderful part show
it because you get to do two ages ah no
of course we all have an idea of what
sherlock holmes's and which I share it's
the traditional one it is based of
course on the conan doyle short stories
and it's been played on as an idea with
you call the post modern versions of him
but this is unique it's not a script
anyone else has played so i'm not
trampling over anyone's territory and no
one's played homes as old as this and
none of them have taken the basic
conceit which is the wonderful starting
point that sherlock holmes is not a
character he's a real person and he's
alive in 1947 and so was i
I could have been the little boy no
Laura you share your scenes all both of
all of your scenes with you know a
veteran lanky and then also with a very
very young performer is this his film
debut so remarkable it's not he's he's I
think he's done one film before once
before and now he's making a very big
movie at the moment so but but Milo is I
I loved being around milan yeah I've
been very very fortunate a lot of the
children who I've worked with have been
have been very very dear and I've you
know I missed them all actually Milo and
I text each other a lot you know he's in
school and he's a wonderful family and
he's that face just would melt my heart
you know that just a little face he has
a very young face in a very old face at
the same time you could you know so I
had I had a lot of fun with my own he's
a real is a real boy he's not an actor
he's not an actor he doesn't try and
overly impress he doesn't try and show
off he doesn't he very much wants to do
right but it doesn't affect his behavior
that way he's not acting at doing it
right he just he's very present that
he's very dear and he's um you know he's
just a sweet sweet boy when working with
an actor of that age does that change
your approach at all do you try to get
things out of him through your own
performance you hear of directors you
know doing that when they themselves are
yeah that's hideous is it hideous I
thought that's I think that's borders on
abusive yeah frankly I'm that's just my
that's just my pet strew when you're
doing it to an adult as well I mean
that's not acting that's terrorizing you
know I understand the desire when you
don't know how to handle a situation but
their other one I just feel there other
ways to go about it but I think what it
does for me is it makes me much more
observant you know because i'm watching
a very fresh faced person discover
things really for the first time this is
someone who hasn't had a lot of time on
us
that who hasn't and it makes me see
things that I you know that are new so I
I really like working with children who
want to be there and who are there for
the right reasons the children who were
not quite comfortable in their own skin
while they're working who were confused
and trying too hard and wanting to
please that's that can be hard and then
you spend a lot of time trying to calm
them down and make them feel okay and
make them feel safe and that that can be
an added responsibility that you don't
necessarily want to take on you do but
it's it costs a little bit but but at
least but Milo and I just just had fun
talk about your accent which is flawless
I'm not British but it seemed pretty
flawless to me well I have you waited
excellent excellence very very specific
I I said to her I don't know quite where
you come from but not because it because
it was so specific I I dare say what did
he call those not linguist people who
finet assist finna Titian I would
probably be able to tell you where mr.
Monroe was born I mean the street was
that accurate I had a lot of help and it
took them a while to figure out where
they wanted her to come from for a while
they move the accent a while a little
bit so I would learn one accent and then
they go no not that and they move it
somewhere else and so so there was a bit
of a time where my head was in a bit of
a spin but they finally landed on that
sort of softer Sussex southern England
sort of sound with it with a little mix
of West just a slight to indicate that
someone who had moved around a bit and
we just will you just work hard at it
you work very technically added at first
and then you you work at it more and
more and then it sort of starts to take
root and then you get a little more
comfortable and then you let it sort of
and then you have to connect it to your
breath so that doesn't just sound like a
bunch of sounds so it takes it a little
bit of patience you have to be scared
you let yourself be scared about it at
first
and you just have to work through
feeling awkward and then all of a sudden
it you know just with repetition and
with practice and with you know thought
behind accent has a lot to to do with it
well it will change the rhythm of speech
and this because there's rhythm of
speech and there's dialect and so all of
those things sort of have to come
together so that they don't you don't
sound like a robot it just takes a
little bit of time in a very good
teacher which fortunately I had what
specifically about I know you wanted to
work with Bill but obviously something
about the project must have appealed to
you on that level can you speak to that
it was all sorts of things that the film
was ticked every box that I I might put
down I often when I'm wondering about
doing a job or where to go on holiday or
you know who to invite to the party the
pros and the cons list and everything
was pro who's directing it who's in it
what's the part like where are we doing
it is there enough money to make it how
long have we got do I trust everybody
everything was everything was a tick and
so it proved and but even so having made
it I wondered well who it would appeal
to I mean difficult in marketing this
film do you say it's Sherlock Holmes
because if it is those who want to
repeat of the Conan Doyle stories pure
and simple will be unsettled nothing
wrong with being unsettled as an audit
but I didn't want to treat them don't
want to explain that this was about a
real man i was called shallow cops and
then I thought the marketing began with
this movie and they said oh the
demographic is retirees
I said well you tell me only old people
are interested in old people because
that is not my experience my experience
is that young people are quite
interested to know people and vice versa
and thus want great joys about our
business that you get to work with
people of all ages don't you find and
then there's a ten-year-old boy in it
for goodness a why shouldn't 10 your
nose enjoy this film and in UK that's
what happened let's get the demographic
is across the range